like people don't like pain it's why
most people don't have six-packs a few
moments later pretty sexy out there you
got your prospectus
[Music]
being welcomed a sprinter and savvy
investor was there any apprehension
about entering the cannabis game No and
then put dot dot dot dot dot dot dot and
the reason it's just a one-word answer
is it's binary
either you want to be on the right side
of history or you don't and I'm
completely convinced that me entering
the space is is going to be viewed
historically correct in your opinion
what does the cannabis industry need to
do with weird surprise you know I think
it needs to go through its natural
progression of wild wild west to
corporate I think it's happening faster
than I would like to see it
I think corporations have been quick to
absorb this industry and I think you're
gonna have a little bit of a gender
fication conflict but uh it's it doesn't
need anything for me it doesn't need
anything from anybody it's naturally
gonna progress them to one of the
biggest industries in the world an
accelerated version of this where a lot
of pretenders will be wiped out the
economy will probably collapse in that
five years so I think some of the hyper
overvaluation will correct itself but it
itself will continue to grow no
different than Amazon continuing to grow
tour in 2001 and - even though the
internet bubble burst it
what do you want to tell the
nine-year-old myself raising my 9 year
old self you [ __ ] did it
I don't know man it's [ __ ] real and
what's crazy about is like it's like all
meant to be man this [ __ ] split shift
to nowadays every day five days are you
I don't call in but I do that one thing
every day but for this my education for
the foot game for that and it's all
thanks to you I appreciate it man I
really I'm so happy better
what did you how much better what's it
what's been flipping well shoes toys I'm
wearing arbitrage my finger right by an
eBay selling Amazon threat correct yeah
I believe in that [ __ ] a lot right
that's huge and this is just season
right right yeah holla queue for how
long we've been doing it I've been doing
it for about three months three months
and it's it's like way more effective
than you could have ever dreamed right
it's it's crazy like people don't like
literally I believe people do make
$100,000 a year I mean just going to
Target and Walmart buying something
coming home and posting it on Amazon
it's amazing it's crazy and it's you
just had to take a little bit convincing
from my family they should see the proof
in the pudding
and I'm doing it and it's like
conditioning as in like the cynicism or
like as in like everybody throw in five
thousand bucks I have a pretty good job
right pretty good job I want to be my
own boss but you're not crazy that oh
yeah exactly yeah I mean that to me is
like it's a the reason I'm jumping on
that statement is like the amount of
people that don't do what they want to
do because convincing like to me the
reason I asked you like convincing a
family as in like you're asking them for
money no right so to me that it goes to
the part that I'm like what like how
many people out there aren't as strong
as you and never do anything because the
judgement of their family stops him from
doing [ __ ] every single thing I've ever
done in my life people thought was
stupid until they did it well cuz when
you do something early or that isn't
mainstream yet it's always gonna be met
with cynicism the internet was a fad
when I started the whole thing the whole
[ __ ] internet not flipping not
Instagram the whole [ __ ] framework
was gonna be gone by the year 2000 all
these people told me
y2k is gonna kill the Internet this is
some of the [ __ ] that I heard from like
people that didn't know it's good man
I'm really happy one
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm curious them I'm probably both in
you guys biggest fans and I like once
you've made it what continues to drive
you to do what it is that you're
passionate about you know for me it's um
I felt like I made it the way you're
asking the question when I made a
hundred thousand dollars a year that was
like there's I've never done anything
financial a lot of good things have
happened to me that has remotely hit my
radar more than the year I made a
hundred thousand a year I would argue
that if you really knew everything about
me and you read it off every action I
ever did you would look me in the face
and ask me why do you sabotage yourself
in business and financials environments
and I would tell you that deep down
subconsciously I love it so much that I
just want it to happen forever and so
for me making it is is a four you know
it just there is that's what that's what
blows me away about somebody was like I
just need to make a million bucks and
I'm gonna go to Jamaica right or or like
I I don't have that I don't have that in
my head I just want to play forever
and that's why I'm trying to get people
to understand the process because I've
it is very clear to me that people that
are in love with their craft and process
can win and that's why I'm trying to
change the conversation around how much
money you need to be happy because it
doesn't work like I just know
unbelievable amounts of data of how many
people have lots of money how many
people don't have lots of money by our
standards and how happy they are and it
doesn't take a lot of money to be you
know to be alive in society it's about
what you spend it money on I mean I
can't get over this I just really wish
people liked what they did because the
game is very simple if you've got debt
or have to put a roof over your head or
somebody else then you work whatever job
is paying you that but I'm asking you
what are you doing from 6:00 p.m. to
midnight and if you have to go build
slowly your portfolio your Shopify store
your Instagram account
your YouTube channel the content like
like wouldn't you be pumped if I told
you for the next four years it's tough
and you don't watch as much Netflix and
Sports and hanging out but then you get
to live happy for the rest of your life
everybody in theory would sign up for
that the reality is a lot of people
don't want to grind for four years like
people don't like pain it's why most
people don't have six-packs I mean that
I mean that there's a lot of people here
who want to be a better shape you just
don't want to workout you just don't
want to eat well like I lived it for the
first thirty eight years of my life and
then I got into better shape I still
hate it I [ __ ] was pissed this
morning waking up at five fifty five to
work out but because I want it and so
I've gone through doing something that
didn't come natural to me that I hate to
this day four and a half years later but
I just want to live 15 years longer and
so for me it's like if you're if any
person here is unhappy I need to know
every single minute you spend on
anything but your job because I'll tell
you taking those leisure hours which
you're using to escape your unhappiness
you're literally watching Netflix or
sports or video playing video games or
listening to music to escape your
reality that you're not happy about I
want you to take those hours and start
building something that gets you off
your issue and it might take seven years
but it's worth it you're gonna everybody
here is gonna live for [ __ ] 60 70
more years people got tricked 54 is
young 54 is young and so people have
terrible ability to put time in
perspective which is why their behaviors
are so broken
[Applause]
my god [ __ ] me that was more like 10
pretty sexy about what's at power
building relationships coordinate
relationships it's the only it means the
only thing that has long-term value is
actual relationships that is the
currency that's how life works
[Music]
I run a travel website and I like for
study Rus and as I just graduated
college I travel to all the time
internationally while I was in school I
settled down working a finite school I
told him the chance to travel and create
that content right now what do I do and
I'm stuck at it you can you can
absolutely create a framework of
freelancers who live in those spots who
can create that content every single
person's that [ __ ] content
[Music]